hi
everyone welcome to today's homeroom we
have a very
exciting special conversation with a dr
fauci
coming in a few seconds but i will make
my standard announcement reminding
everyone that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization
we can only exist with support from
donors like yourself so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org
slash donate i want to give a special
shout out to
several organizations that stepped up
when they realized that we were already
running into deficit pre-covet and
in our efforts to support all the
schools and learners around the world
due to school closures
have helped to step up to to close that
gap
special thanks to bank of america
google.org at t
fastly novartis and the amgen foundation
but we're still running at a gap
and so anything any of you all can do to
help is very much appreciated
so with that out of the way i'm super
excited
to have today dr anthony fauci who i
think
needs no introduction uh thank you so
much for joining us dr fauci
good to be with you so thank you for
having me
so as you can imagine and i'm sure
you're at the center of this i've been
getting a ton of questions from
everyone i know for for uh what they
want to go over but you know i actually
want to start just
you know on you personally how are
things going for you
uh how are you know how's the stress
level how are you handling it
you know how how are you dealing with
with everything that's going on
well i'm dealing with it but i think it
would not be honest if i say it wasn't
very stressful
this is a very difficult situation we're
going through the historic pandemic
and the amount of demands for what we
need to do
i'm simultaneously running the institute
that i direct which is
the national institute of allergy
infectious diseases which is responsible
for most of the science that goes into
covid particularly developing a vaccine
and developing therapies
and diagnostics and i'm also a member of
the coronavirus
task force which is i know charged with
as you well know
the responsibility for trying to provide
direction and guidance
to the country and we're in a very
difficult situation so yes it's
extremely stressful but it is what i do
i've been doing this my entire
professional life going back
40 years for the beginning of hiv aids
and
all the other outbreaks that we had to
contend with
so this is part of the job but it's uh
it's where
it where it's wearing it's not easy
but i could always well i can only
imagine but i i think i speak for all
americans and actually people around the
world saying that you know you've been a
source of comfort throughout and
my wife's a physician and if i've ever
felt insecure about my marriage it's
based on how much she's been a fan girl
of you i actually have your
your principles of internal medicine
right over
here uh so this has been uh it's great
to talk to you but
you know getting into i'm sure what
you've been
really steeped in and been talking about
a lot
before i even start talking about school
closures and and what might
may or may not make sense i'd love to
just get our framing and where we
are in this journey together there's a
lot of conversations now about vaccines
from moderna from astrazeneca
where are we in that journey it looks
like we're getting into kind of the
phase three if the more you can explain
that and and what you think will how
it'll play out over the next few months
well that's a great question if the
journey is the vaccine journey
it's very clear where we are so so
i think one needs to point out that
historically
this is the fastest we've ever launched
into a process of developing
safe and effective vaccines for an
important disease
in history i mean the the speed with
which this happened it was a combination
of the technology which allowed us to do
that with new vaccine platforms
which could start on bona fide vaccine
development literally
within days of knowing what the sequence
of a particular pathogen is as opposed
to having to grow it up
and getting it isolated and purified
we saved at least a year or more by
technological advances
alone so a number of trials you know
there are
dozens of vaccines that are going into
phase different phases of trials which
i'll explain in a moment
um about a dozen or between a half a
dozen and a dozen
are the ones that are really getting
involved in proceeding
in good faith with with uh with trials
take one if for example the modern one
that you mentioned
so we started a phase one trial only 62
days
after we actually started developing the
vaccine
those results were published in the new
england journal of medicine
and they look pretty good in the sense
that even though
there's a limited number of people 45 15
per dose three doses that the induction
of neutralizing antibodies
that were comparable to the levels that
you would get with convalescent plasma
are very promising a phase two study has
also been done
and literally a couple of days from now
on july 27th we're going to enter into a
phase three trial
so for your audience so that people
understand
phase one looks just at safety and the
kind of
response that you induce is it safe and
does it look like it's inducing the
response you'd like to see it
phase two amplifies that so phase one
has like 45
individuals phase two has hundreds of
individuals
phase three is thousands of individuals
so on
july 27th 30 000 people
we're not going to do them all on july
27th but there will be a trial that will
be started
with 30 000 people to determine
does it really work in other words we're
doing the trial
in those areas of the country where
there's
active virus infection which is not
difficult to find because
we have pretty widespread active
infection
to determine does it really work how
long does that
take it generally takes several
months at best with some vaccines it
might take
years but there's so much virus
activity out there that it is likely
we'll get a good idea of whether we do
have a safe and effective vaccine
or not within a period of several months
so that you can say somewhere towards
the
end of this calendar year
and the beginning of 2021 that's just
with
one candidate there are other candidates
that one month later
and one month later and one month later
will be going into phase three trials
so it's a group of several at least six
or more that are going to be going
gradually into phase three trial
now no one can ever guarantee salt
whether you have a safe and effective
vaccine
the proof of the pudding is you've got
to do the trial
which we're doing my projection
which is just cautious optimism is no
guarantee
is that by the end of the year the
beginning of 2021
we'll have a vaccine that we could start
distributing to people
so that's the timetable it's extremely
quick
but it's not sacrificing safety nor is
it sacrificing
scientific integrity it's just doing
things more quickly
by essentially going to the next step
and taking a financial risk before
you actually get the answer to the
previous step
and there's a lot in there that's really
really interesting one just to make sure
that folks are tracking with us
even in these phase ones one you're just
making sure that the vaccine isn't doing
obvious harm that's you know do no harm
first step and
also to your point the fact that the
antibodies are showing up these are the
things that tag
parts of the virus to to kind of get
cleaned up by our immune system so in
theory
if the antibodies are showing up they'll
be able to tag the virus and the virus
won't be able to spread the way
it typically would and then phase two
you go a little bit further with that
and then as we go into phase three is it
do you
focus this on communities where there's
already a lot of spread so that you can
really see the difference whether the
vaccine's making a difference are you
are you focused on
the antibody still or now are you
focused on hey three months from now
what percentage of the people in the
treatment group got the vaccine or the
severity
versus didn't get it that's a great
great introduction to a really
important question so what it is is that
the phase three the primary endpoint
is whether or not you prevent someone
from getting a
clinically recognizable infection that's
the primary endpoint
you also are going to be measuring the
antibodies
because you want to get a correlate of
immunity you want to find out
what you induce in a person that is
directly associated
with protection so the bottom line is
when you get to phase 3
you want to know not just what the
laboratory data is
you want to know have you protected
someone from getting clinically
recognizable
infection because then later on you
could do
correlates and use that immune response
to be able to predict whether other
vaccines
are going to be able to protect
and you know one interesting thing you
mentioned
is the you know normally and to give
credit to this whole system here
normally a vaccine could take many years
sometimes as long as a decade to develop
to your point the development started
within days of having the sequence
of the rna of the virus and then what
the government is doing is essentially
taking these pre-bets normally you would
wait for stage three to finish
say oh it works now let's start
manufacturing but the government has
already placed orders with
these companies so they can start
manufacturing
uh just in case it it you know assuming
it's good if it's not lost money if it
how is that thinking how does that
thinking go how does the decision treat
work
okay i'll tell you exactly right again
good introduction to a very important
question
so in general pharmaceutical companies
although they want to help public health
they are a business
they have got to function like a
business even though many of them are
very altruistic in what they do
so they cannot lose a lot of money
so what they generally do is that they
wait
until one step is proven before they
start manufacturing at
big scale to get it ready the good
news for them is that they are playing
it
safe they're not risking the bad
news is that delays by months and months
whether you're going to have vaccine
that you can actually
distribute what the government has done
is to the tune of billions of dollars
they've invested to do just that at the
risk
to the government's money they do
advanced
purchase agreements to say no matter
what happens
we will buy 300 million doses
of the vaccine now if the vaccine
doesn't work
then the company doesn't really lose
much but
we lose money we feel the government
to the extent that i represented i don't
really represented it because i'm a
scientist who does the research but we
feel
it is worth the financial risk
to allow us to get that much more of a
head start
on getting an effective vaccine to the
people who need it
yeah and the math the way it works it's
all probabilistic but
it makes a ton of sense that if if
there's even a 60
chance or 70 chance that you can get a
vaccine
into the world three months faster four
months faster that's going to save maybe
trillions of dollars
of savings and not to mention lives uh
which
seems like a a really really smart
calculus there
it is it's a bit but it's a good bet
yeah
and i what do you see as a probability
you know
let's say you're already making the bet
of the manufacturing you're already
essentially
kind of buying the vaccine hoping that
it will work
assuming that the stage 3 trials go well
and it starts getting the doses start
hitting the market in in january
february
how long will it be before we have a
critical mass of the vaccine out there
that it can really start to affect
how much how much virus is out there in
the population
that's a good question um you're talking
about
vaccinating a few hundred million people
in the united states
notwithstanding that you also have a
global responsibility all of us
of taking care of countries that don't
have the resources
to do it logistically alone
that takes time so you wouldn't be able
it will take months
to do that months to vaccinate that many
people
but you know we've done major
vaccination campaigns before
we did it with polio globally we did it
with smallpox
it can be done but it's not easy because
it isn't like you can go into the office
and get your shot for this
in your shot for that this is a massive
public health campaign
and what is there a threshold in
epidemiology that if
x percent get the vaccine then where
we've essentially turned the tide
you know it's called hurt immunity in
other words if you get enough people
protected
that means that the rest of the people
who are not
protected will be protected because
there's so much
uh blocking of the virus in the
community an umbrella of protection
the virus has no place to go because it
can't find susceptible people because
most of them are protected that critical
level
varies from pathogen to pathogen from
virus to virus
we don't know exactly what that number
is
for covid but we assume it's somewhere
around
70 75 but we don't know so we have to be
humble and realize we don't know what
that is because there are so many
moving target factors here
and what is um
is there a sense of that the vaccine if
it's effective that
and the antibodies are there that it's
essentially a permanent vaccination or
are is there some possibility that
there's something unique about kovid
that it's
something of a temporary immunity well
there is some somewhat sobering
information we get
if you look now even though we're only
six months
into the outbreak and it's very
difficult to give a projection
of durability of immunity one two three
years out
we have no idea because we've only been
involved with this infection
for six months but a sobering aspect of
the information
is that in people who've been infected
and recovered and you
follow them and find out how long the
antibodies last
it's variable sum it lasts for as long
as you follow them which would be
at the most six months for others in
several weeks it goes down significantly
which means that the immunity that's
durable
isn't like measles which is like for the
rest of your life
you're protected the durability of the
immunity is so great
so this means that we have to keep an
eye out on this that it likely
will protect enough for the season
as it were but then you got to follow
people
and if a certain percentage of them fall
below
a critical level after x number of
months
or a year or two years
you may have to think about giving them
a boost the way we give
many things many pathogens that we have
vaccines for we have to boost them
tetanus you have to boost every 10 years
some of the others you have to boost
every once in a while
and and you know given that this could
be you know based on these
this analysis you know many months it
could go well through the school year
obviously you know we're
an online learning organization a lot of
the interest has been around what to do
with schools
uh this coming back to school maybe a
good place to start is what do we know
about how well or not so well kids
can be vectors for the for the virus
i've seen some research that 10 and
under
there doesn't seem to be a lot of
evidence that the kids are spreading it
what do you know about that what's the
latest there well that's that's the same
korean study that you're referring to
that
everybody's quoting now it came out last
week and it showed exactly what you said
saul
that children up to 10 don't seem to be
transmitting to adults as efficiently as
adults
transmit to adults whereas 10 to 19
it appears that children transmit to
adults as well as adults
transmit to adults well we really don't
know because there are so many studies
and the percentage varies from country
to country is that do children get
as easily infected as adults the way you
know that
is that you look at the percent of
infection in children
compared to the percent of infection in
the general
population if it's significantly less
that means children
don't get infected that as much if it's
more or
the same that means they easily get
infected
what we're doing here at the nih we're
doing a study
it's called heroes for human
epidemiology of coviden
uh covet infection and what it does it
looks at
it started on may first and we'll get
significant data
by december 2020 and what it is it's a
study
of six thousand people in two thousand
families
looking at the rate and the prevalence
and the incidence of infection
in children and whether or not they
transmit it to adults or do adults
transmit it to them
we should know the answer to that in a
good study by the end of december
of 2020.
and so given that if you were a district
superintendent or school principal how
would you be thinking about that i've
seen guidelines from folks like
the harvard global health initiative
where they essentially have kind of a
colored ranking based on the prevalence
of new
cases in a geography and if it's red
you're at full distance if it's
green full somewhat normalcy with social
distancing
in between maybe you open for the
kindergartners or for the
you know the 10 and under and then you
you kind of play it by year for middle
school students how would you be
thinking about it uh as a district
official right now
the same way i think the critical issue
and you know you could break it down
into green yellow and
and red but what the what the officials
need to do
is to look at the level of activity of
virus in the community
because what we get confused at is we
make the united states a unidimensional
phenomenon it's not it's very much
different
geographically demographically in the
level of infection
so there will be some states cities
districts
counties where the level of infection is
so low
that you don't have to worry about
anything regarding bringing your
children back to school just
bring them back to school no problem but
there are some in which you have a level
of activity
where you got to balance if you are
going to bring the children back
what do you need to worry about what
should you do and it's a whole set of
recommendations that come from the cdc
and they are things like alternating
classes
morning afternoon alternating days
monday wednesday friday tuesday thursday
what have you physical separation and
class
seating people six feet apart having
children who can tolerate it wear a mask
all the time have the teachers wear a
mask there are so many things you could
do
alternate between online and in person
those are the things you need to do and
then you could make a decision
as you said if i were a superintendent i
would look at where
my district was what the risk is and i'd
fashion
the process of getting kids back to
school
based on that estimation
and and would you say that you know i
think what a lot of district officials
are looking for is some type of a
threshold
uh uh to so they can be confident that
they're doing the right thing because
they they're feeling like these are life
in debt situations i know the harvard
global health
initiative that's just the one that i
looked at where they have thresholds
like you know 10 new cases
per 100 000 per day this is the scenario
that you should think about 25
new cases per 100 000 do you think those
are the the right types of things that
district officials should anchor on
yeah absolutely take a look at what what
the percent positivity is
and from a teacher's point of view you
know i think we've all heard in the
press
teacher fears especially if some of them
are in high risk groups i have this
question from facebook diane newman is
asking if people
over 60 are more likely to get this and
have severe symptoms
should they be forced to go back to
school do you recommend they go back
and then it says currently many
districts are requiring all their
employees to come back to school unless
they have a doctor's note
how do you think about that um
you know you asked about three or four
questions there
so what i think is that obviously you've
got to pay attention
to the concerns of teachers who are
entering into the elderly demographic
bracket
particularly those who have underlying
conditions
you know you talk about the elderly
there aren't a lot
i think at least the elderly people that
i know
there aren't a lot of elderly people
that don't have at least one
underlying condition besides old age
and that is you know they're either
hypertensive they have mild
cardiovascular
disease a little chronic lung disease
maybe diabetes
there are a lot of people with
underlying conditions out there so i
think when you
talk about forcing teachers to come back
to school
you better be careful about that and
make sure you pay attention
to a keeping them safe and kee keeping
them healthy
and in terms of the actual
implementation of that
you know a lot of questions i'll just
try to group them together that i'm
getting off of youtube and facebook
right now is
questions about you know you mentioned
things like social distance how do you
do that within a
physical environment i am curious a lot
of people asking questions about outdoor
school
uh you know there's previous epidemics
tuberculosis
where even in fairly cold places they
seemingly effectively did school
outdoors well is that something that you
would recommend
folks go in that direction or it's
really you know district by district
no i think district by district but i
can tell you
as a public health man uh uh a
paradigm outdoors is always better than
indoors when it comes to covert or any
other respiratory infection
because when you get recirculating air
indoor you got to be careful
so if there's anything that you could do
outdoors
as opposed to indoors i would do it that
could be school
certainly it could be restaurants i mean
restaurants if they
possibly have the capability of having
outdoor seating
as opposed to indoor seating i would
stress that
and and that's super helpful and from
facebook we have this question from
aaron elizabeth
we live in a state where cases are on
the rise and schools are starting to
formulate plans the latest is that they
may not
mandate masks can you share opinion on
uh can you share your opinion of masks
in schools
yes i believe that if you're dealing
with a situation which
is almost everywhere in the united
states where there's there electivity
that you wear masks that children who
can
tolerate because i mean i've i have
three girls
they're adults now but i remember them
lovingly very well when they were
young kids i don't think i could keep a
mask
you don't want a kid who's really young
but to the extent that you can i would
and certainly teachers
yeah our five and a half year old we've
had to just make him play like he's a
ninja and then it becomes that much
better
so this is a question actually this one
i've been wondering myself from facebook
anne marie byron's asks dear dr fauci is
it okay to wear
face shield instead of a mask in the
classroom or i guess you could say even
in general
i think students need to see their
teachers faces so much of encouragement
and engagement comes through a teacher's
smile
well this is a face shield
it's not a mask it's cloth i wear this
all the time
i i you know rotate i usually wear a
washington nationals uh face mask
to cheer on my team but but these are
fine
these types of things are fine and i see
there's some new things coming out with
have the
where the mouth part is clear so that i
guess people can see your you're smiling
what do you what about the
the kind of the plastic full shields do
those provide any protection
yeah yeah they do so you see the only
trouble is that
someone will bring up the possibility
that they're okay
my staff just brought this in
there you go that's great
yeah so this is good yeah this is good
for droplets
because it'll block it the only trouble
is if you have any degree of aerosol
what happens is that all of this see it
can go right in like that
that's the problem you see so these are
good for droplets but
you have to be careful if there's a
degree of aerosolization
and do those pro because part of the
mask or the shield
it's protecting yourself but part of it
is also protecting other people
does the shield help at all with
protecting other people i guess you know
things won't get projected as far
around they would go around see i think
people need to understand and
this may be a good a good rationale
because you really want to get people to
rationally go along with why you should
wear a mask
is that we became really bullish
on masks when it became clear
that a substantial proportion of people
22 to 45 percent
are asymptomatic they don't even know
they're infected
and we know that someone is asymptomatic
can pass the virus on to another person
which is
innocent and inadvertent nobody's trying
to infect anybody
you just don't know you're infected so
what we do know
is that a face covering or a mask
can prevent me if i were inadvertently
and unknowingly infected it would
prevent me from infecting
you so it's almost like a responsibility
you wear a mask to protect me and i wear
a mask to protect you
so we're all in this together and when
people realize that that may be more of
a motivation
of them to do that that it's almost like
your societal responsibility
to not be part of the problem of
propagating an outbreak
as opposed to saying oh i'm a young
person i don't care if i get infected
doesn't make any difference it does
because even if you don't
get any symptoms and you're infected and
don't know it
the chances are you're going to pass
your infection
onto someone else who then pass it on to
someone else
and then you'll pass it on to someone
who could be someone's mother
who's undergoing chemotherapy for cancer
or an imminent deficient
child or someone who has another
condition
diabetes very common condition and then
that person
is at high risk for a bad outcome
that's super important and i know we're
almost out of time
you know first of all dr fauci i just i
genuinely want to thank you and i think
i'm speaking on behalf of
tens of millions of people around the
world that you are a source of grounding
and comfort in this very very tough time
and i can only imagine
the weight you feel on your shoulders is
there are there any parting messages
that you'd like to share i mean you just
shared a few
you know just things that people haven't
fully grocked or digested that you just
really want to doubly underline
yeah i i think what you start to see so
is fatigue on people
no one likes to be isolated relatively
speaking
from society i certainly miss it i know
everyone that i come into contact feels
that way
just keep in mind this will end we will
end this terrible scourge that we're
under so
hang in there don't get discouraged
throw up your hands and say oh i'm just
tired of it i'm just gonna do things i
don't care
if i wind up getting infected hold tight
hang in there we're all in it together
and it will
end and we will get back to our normal
lives
within a reasonable period of time
that's a message i'd like people to hear
no definitely appreciate that i think a
lot of people need to hear that thank
you so much dr fauschi this was super
valuable
thank you and i appreciate you giving me
the opportunity to be on your show
so uh thanks everyone for joining uh
once again another incredible
conversation
you know i think dr fauci for those of
you don't know he's obviously
been catapulted into into fame because
of this unfortunate situation we're in
but my wife's a physician and she's been
following him for a while
he's one of the top physicians um in the
field
for for many decades now so we're very
lucky to have him and we're frankly very
lucky to have him in this position of
leadership right now
but thanks everyone for joining this
live stream and i look forward to
more conversations like this in the
weeks ahead
you